hey what's up on today's show i talked
to an awesome mom of
three who's asking for help on how to
stop keeping score
in her relationship with her husband i
also talked to a mom
of two young kids whose husband has
another son that the little ones don't
know about
and they want to know how to have that
conversation and finally
talk to a young man who's caught in a
psychological trap between mom
and dad and he doesn't know what to do
yikes stay tuned
hey what's up what's up this is delony
with the dr john deloney show
the show's about you it's for you it's
your calls your challenges your problems
your concerns with what's going on in
your heart in the mirror
in the hearts and minds of your kids
your spouse
girlfriend or boyfriend your country
man there's a lot going on there's a lot
of hurting people
but there's a lot of joy too
there's a lot of joy too there's a lot
of we just need to figure out the next
thing and we're gonna get it we're gonna
get it this messiness
the good stuff the bad stuff all of it
i'm here to walk alongside you
and my commitment to you is i'm gonna
tell you the truth i'm not gonna
not gonna lie to you i'm not gonna
gaslight you i'm gonna tell you the
truth
even when it's hard even when i tell you
the truth
and i get off the show no i gotta go
make some changes in my life and that's
happened
already i'm walking alongside with you
if you're new to this band of
of of cool figuring it out folks
right we talk about mental health
challenges family and relational iq
questions schooling education parenting
addiction marriage all of it
right and sometimes we talk about good
stuff sometimes we talk about hard stuff
but listen
i got this email i didn't ask this
person's permission so i'm just gonna
call him
um uh mike mike emailed in
and i just i just needed to say man this
this made my day
um if you listen to a podcast from the
last podcast it downloaded you know that
um
i put something on the interwebs and got
in trouble for it
i didn't get trouble for it the internet
police the commenters
whoo they did not want us coming
together
at the same exact moment
10 55 a.m i got a email
that's telling me what a terrible human
i was at the same
moment this email from mike comes in
and mike writes john i've never called
in but i've been applying your advice
about
grounding our kids and my love as their
dad
i've been touching their face before bed
holding them close
locking eyes with them just to say i'm
glad you are my son
we have three high energy boys 10 five
and five
and a four-year-old daughter with down
syndrome
for the past 10 years i felt
increasingly disconnected because i'm
personally dealing with a chronic and
debilitating health condition
that consumes more time and energy than
i would like
i didn't know how to connect with them
well and after listening to your show i
realized i need to step
up and give this quack on the radio a
shot yes
dave ramsey taught me how to manage my
money exposed my lack of discipline and
showed me how to change
my character and you're teaching me how
to be a better dad and husband
thanks mike brother mike listen
you're an absolute hero you're
you're a inspiration to me as a dad too
of two young kids
you got four man you live in a hurricane
i'm just living in a tropical storm
but i'm gonna go home and intentionally
make sure
i'm doubling down on connecting with my
two kids tonight because
you reminded me in your note we are all
figuring this out together
i'm proud of you this is hard especially
if you're a dad who's never seen this
happen if you're a mom who doesn't have
a picture of what connecting with her
kids
actually looks like it's hard to do
and mike you can get me choked up here
before the show even starts man
but i'm i'm grateful for you this is
awesome we'll be cheering you on
if we can help along the way if i can
give you a shout along the way holler at
me man
we're so glad to have you give me a call
anybody mike
everybody 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
show and fill out the form if you want
to be on the show we'd love to have you
talking about anything let's go straight
to the phones let's go to marie in
austin texas
dear marie what's going on how are we
doing
hey dr john doing great thanks so much
for taking my call today
thank you for calling i'm really
grateful for it so what can i do to help
yeah so i would just love your advice on
how my husband and i can overcome the
trap we sometimes
fall into of keeping score
so can i i want to change your language
right off the bat okay
sure instead of falling into traps i
want you to
change your analogy to we're in a funky
dance
okay okay funky dance we are in a dance
that isn't helping
we're stepping on each other's feet and
so we just need to learn how to dance
better
when you fall into a trap you just start
rattling the bars
and then you eat the person inside that
trap with you when you're just stepping
on each other's toes you can still look
at each other and i laugh a little bit
right so we're gonna change the metaphor
so
y'all are in a funky dance man you're
not dancing well with one another
tell me about keeping score yeah so just
to kind of give you a little context so
i'm a stay-at-home mom
of three kids under five and
um yes and one of them is an infant and
i also work
part-time from home and my husband
he also works really hard his job could
be physically demanding
at times and sometimes he can have
pretty harsh hours that can reach up to
12 to 16 hour days you know depending on
the day
but most of the time i would say we're a
really great team and we dance well
together
um he's just he's a super great dad
and i mean he's very hands-on he does a
lot of things around the house
um and you know things most of the time
flow
as smoothly as possible as i can with
the house of three kids um
where our where we start to step on each
other's toes a little bit
is um usually around the time whenever
work
is really busy for him um which
consequently makes
really hard days for me as well because
i'm at home with
three kids all day long running the show
um and so then that's where we can kind
of
start stepping on each other's toes of
you know who's
who's doing more or who's more tired
so i can you know let's say by the end
of the night
you know getting the kids in bed and um
i've got you know a pile of dishes in
the sink from a dinner that i just
cooked and
um you know laundry piled up and he's
okay to sit on the couch and rest
you know he's had a long day um but i
have two
right right so who's who's the chief
scorekeeper
is it you i mean probably yes
so hey listen
it's the same issue if somebody is the
super score keeper
and somebody doesn't even know there's a
score being kept both of those things
will poison a relationship
right but i just wanted to know is he
the one laying on the couch
and you say hey man you're i just have a
picture of you holding one baby there's
another one
wrapped around your leg and another one
is flushing things down the toilet
and he's like clean my kitchen he's not
that guy he's not even paying attention
at all huh
right right and you are you
okay so tell me if i'm right here okay
and so
typically you know i'll say something
like
hey you know like let's get up and do
this together so then we can
we can both rest at the same time and
and he'll say well i'll you know i'll
get to it later which
he doesn't and he he's okay with letting
things
be kind of undone and i kind of feel
like i'm drowning
and by the time i communicate it i've
already been over
like i'm already overwhelmed and
frustrated okay so that's it that's the
magic right there
okay so by the time you
ask for help he already has set
sail on his
right right by the time you say hey i
need some help
that fire's already burning right even
if he got up and helped at that moment i
can't believe i even had to ask him
i'm sitting here all day and then you
start counting off that list
and so you know this but i'm gonna say
it for everybody listening
and i want you to imprint this on your
heart
okay okay score keeping in a
relationship
leads to only one outcome resentment
and resentment leads to the death of a
relationship a hundred percent of the
time
okay and so what you've got to do is
right now it's annoying and you're
driving yourself crazy and you know
intellectually like i shouldn't i know
he's working hard
i hate him right now but i love him and
i know he's working hard right
and you are wiping that third baby's
booty
harder and harder like oh i'm just going
to do this and this
right and so what you end up doing is
the story you tell yourself
is that you are the hardest worker and
the story he tells himself is
i've worked really hard and my wife has
created this sanctuary for me and i'm
gonna go enjoy it
and then he collapses and hey will you
help yeah i'm for sure i'm gonna do that
i'm he's never going to right i don't
know a lot of guys that lie to their
wives in that moment they really are
planning on doing it
um but they really head off to mars
right and that doesn't make it right
it just makes it an is okay so here's
here's going back to what you said
here's a couple things i want you guys
to do together
and the beautiful thing is this is an
absolutely solvable
challenge in your home right and it
stems from
two people who are doing the best they
can for everybody
and all you want to do now is instead of
having those two horses pull in opposite
directions
you want to get those two horses going
together right so
right the first thing i want you all to
do is to
every single week and i want you to be
vulnerable and ask him about this
because it may be foreign it was foreign
to me
i did not realize how much a simple
30-minute calendar meeting every week
with my wife
gave her peace made her want to make out
with me a lot more
made [ __ ] just feel safer and let her
speak
it gave her an avenue to talk to me
where she didn't feel safe before
right in a calendar meeting she was able
to say
hey on these three nights at about this
time this is when things start to
unravel with our kids this is when i
need you to put this on the calendar
that i need help with these things
that for her gave her safety as opposed
to
coming in and saying hey will you get up
off the couch because you know i worked
hard
but also it's right so it gave her it
gave her some boundaries for a harder
conversation
so i want you to every week it know if
sans or butts
have a and hopefully i can do this with
your budget stuff too
you can do this with your calendar stuff
you can do this with your intimate life
with three little kids
you're gonna have to start planning and
programming
and practicing desire otherwise that
goes away you'll wake up and you'll have
a 15 year old and a 14 year old and a 10
year old and you all have kissed each
other on birthdays only right
and so you're gonna have to i want you
to start to plan those things and it
sounds exhausting now but when you plan
them then they become something you look
forward to as
as opposed to another chore but i want
you all to have the conversation that
says what does the picture of this week
look like
let's get out of calendar he may get out
his phone and say it's the same every
week we just go to
but it doesn't it fluctuates and talk it
through and that's where you can have a
moment of
hey on these nights can you help i need
your
not can you i need you to lean in and
help here and i need your work workday
to extend a little bit
and help me with these things because
this thing i'm drowning here
and my hope is he's a man of character
and i can tell
that you love him and he's a good human
being otherwise this call will be going
way differently
right told in that setting i think he
can hear it
right the same as if his boss called him
and said i need you to stay one more
hour we got this big project he'd be
like bro i'm all in right
i'll do this to his boss the second
thing is
is i want you two to keep a singular
gratitude journal together okay and
every day
you have to write to each other
i am grateful for you have to start it
with three sentences i'm grateful for
and list three things about him and it
may be that those are the same things
every day
during a season i'm grateful you went to
work today i'm grateful that you
bothered to come home today i'm grateful
that you said thank you for my dinner
they may be trite and silly
but what i want you to cultivate is
right now
your your eyes are looking for the
things that he's not doing
i want you to begin to train each
other's hearts and minds and eyes to
look for the things that you are doing
and we find the things that we spend the
energy looking for
and so if i wake up every day looking
for people in the news that hate me
i'm gonna find them and looking for what
what political sides of whatever are
making me angry i'm gonna find that
but if i look for the things that i
agree with and that bring me optimism
and joy i'm going to find that too
and you just got to practice that
because we don't we're not trained how
to do that we're training how to find
problems in people
not optimistic things and he's going to
forget
not because he's a jerk not because he's
uh you know an idiot
he's just gonna forget and you're gonna
have to lean in and be vulnerable and
remind him
okay so here's the third thing okay okay
i want you all to get away if you
haven't and this may be expensive for
y'all
i want you all to get away even if it's
for a morning like a half morning
and here's what couples often don't do
in fact they almost
never do this everything about your
relationship is different
you have three little kids right yes
my guess is you were a rock star
employee is that true
i hope so yes yes you were and then you
chose to take your expertise and your
skill set
and channel it in another direction rock
and roll great
and you're working part time everything
about your just your relationship is
different
and what most couples do is they try to
try to drag
that college relationship that they had
that just
lunatic we stay up all night we're crazy
right
and or they try to drag those first two
or three years of marriage when
we're just walking around naked all the
time and drinking one or two too much we
just
it was just rambunctious and chaos and
then you have kid one and kid two
and what happens is you try to drag that
old life into
kid one and kid two and it all crashes
and then you start blaming one another
because you're tired you start having a
competition on who's more tired and
who's working hard
you guys have to have the fun
and the vulnerability and the scariness
and the excitement of
saying okay everything's new now i love
you you love me
we're gonna have to build something new
off an already
awesome platform so take a half day my
wife and i do this every year
it's an annual retreat we go on but i
want you and your husband to go
on a may just maybe with three little
kids you can just get away for a half
morning have somebody come over
i want you to go to breakfast go
somewhere to eat go for a walk somewhere
and i want you guys to sit down and say
we have three crazy kids
we had sex seven months ago that's how
that worked right
and i love you and you have never done
the dishes and i'm about to smash you
with a fork
and all the china we have and you're
working so hard and i'm so grateful for
you
and i don't tell you this enough but
you're the best mom i've ever
ever met all those things together
and i want you to begin to talk through
hey here's what this is going to look
like for us it's going to be a weird
season we're going to start putting sex
on the calendar we're going to put dates
on the calendar
i'm going to put on my calendar help
with dishes not because i'm a jerk but
because i'm having to learn new skills
and i'm going to ask you not to judge me
when i forget and i just hit the couch
because i've got this pattern now
i want you to say hey man uh can you
help me out and i'm going to go yes yes
i'm in and
i'm going to be tired and we're both
going to hit our heads on the pillow
exhausted at night
and that's gonna be good and this season
isn't gonna last forever but right now
we got three little
three little maniacs that we love and
that are are
ruining everything and fulfilling
everything all at the same time
and we're gonna do this together and i'm
not gonna
have a fight with you when i'm already
exhausted and when i've already been
counting down the things all day
and i need you to hear how incredibly
hard it is to be a stay-at-home mom
and a part-time employee and a
plugged-in wife
it is harder than going to work can ever
and will ever be
i want you to know that and i need you
to hear that and guys listening to this
it's true
it is uh come together in that in that
connection there man and you're talking
awesome so picture of today a weekly
calendar meeting
a gratitude journal that sits on your
bed that you both write in every day
looking for ways to find why you're
grateful about each other
and then get away and begin to recraft
re
re do the architecture work re-engineer
a new relationship that's already built
on a new foundation that includes three
kids that includes two hard jobs that
includes aging parents whatever's going
on in your life
and when you find yourself counting
you know what i did no did just yell
stop stop
because counting and score keeping keep
lead to resentment which leads to death
in the relationship
awesome call marie you rule you made my
whole morning good all right let's go to
melissa in st
louis melissa what's up how are we doing
good dr delaney how are you good it's
deloney it rhymes with baloney it was a
really rough childhood
hey i will take delaney all day that's
easier than deloney but
such it is so what's going on how are
you i'm good thank you so much for
taking my call i really appreciate it no
thank you for calling so what's up how
can i help
so my husband and i have two children we
have a seven-year-old son and a
four-year-old
daughter how long you have been married
as we get in uh ten years
ten years okay yes so as we get into
this age group we find ourselves
constantly teaching them about honesty
and integrity and accountability you
know all those things that you want to
teach them
early in life so that they'll hopefully
be better off as they get older but my
husband and i have
i guess a secret of our own and we need
some help on how to
figure this out for our family okay um
so my husband has a son
um from a one-time indiscretion that our
children do not know about
okay um he's 14 years old and he lives
with his mother
in another state um we provide full
financial support to him
and we had about an eight-year court
battle
to try to establish and develop a
relationship
it wasn't until he was 10 that the
courts mandated that
she produced the child and it was
revealed in court order therapy that she
had told him that his dad was
dead and a deadbeat all of those years
as she was moving around changing her
phone number
changing her name i'm just a very
tumultuous type relationship and we were
kind of always two steps behind her
so once they started court order therapy
he traveled for a year he would do one
week a month
to do therapy and to visit and then at
the end of that year when the judge
asked the child how he felt he just
expressed a lot of anger towards his dad
he didn't want a relationship with him
he didn't want a relationship with our
family
and the judge said that he was going to
honor that and that
if he wanted to when he was ready he
could come around okay
so we felt that we had exhausted all of
our options legally
financially um we incurred a lot of debt
um to make you know to meet that yearly
that monthly requirement
and emotionally we didn't really know
what else to do so we came to terms with
that we worked through that process and
obviously we hope that he'll come around
when he's older and ready to have that
conversation and we don't need to
involve the courts
so i guess our question is you know how
do we tell
our two children about this at what age
is appropriate it's just causing a lot
of anxiety thinking of
opening up something so burdensome that
will leave this hole in their hearts
that they have this brother that
that they don't know but i'm also scared
to wait
until they're you know 30 and 28
and this kid shows up and he's their
brother and they had no idea yeah i
don't
find out that we kept this big secret
from them so yeah don't do that so i
don't want to figure out how
how to navigate that so i'm going to
answer two parts one you didn't ask me
and one
you did okay um i cannot recommend
enough
that your husband leave
a inexhaustible
trail of care and compassion
and intervention with this young boy
what that may look like right now
is a monthly or even weekly letter
that what you're doing is you're
building up months and
years of of
i reached out i reached out i was the
grown-up i was the grown-up i was the
grown-up
there will come a moment when he's going
to want to talk to his dad it will
happen
and there will come a moment when he'll
see things clearly
it just happens that way and it might
not be till he's 30. it might not be
tough 21 there will be moments when he
wants to know
and that's when you want him to know
this guy reached out to me and would not
stop
what a kid is looking for is
that that never ceasing connection and i
cannot
get my feelings hurt by a 14 year old
with a manipulative mother
i can't get my feelings hurt by a 14
year old period
there will come a day when your husband
can pull out all that paperwork and say
look this young man in the eye and say i
went to the ends of the earth for you
i want you to know that but i want this
kid to feel that
okay and so whether that's a
you send pictures of you you and him i
probably wouldn't include your
the two young ones yet um until he's
older
but i want him to know that y'all
reached out and reached out and reached
out and reached out
and one day he'll he'll he'll loop back
around i almost have no question that
will happen
the second part is this you have
a deep well of emotion tied to this
situation
right this kid means a lot to you i bet
if you
i bet you and i could talk offline in
person for about 15 minutes and you
could double over in tears right i mean
i bet it happened pretty quick
um your seven-year-old and your
four-year-old don't have that
they don't have that emotional
connection and all of that baggage and
all that pain associated with it
and so if you let them know you guys
have a brother
and um daddy had another little boy
and he lives with another mommy in this
place
and you leave it at that then they will
go
oh one of them the oldest one may ask
can we go see him and you'll say someday
and you just begin to norm it over time
the less sensationalized you make it the
more
fact-based you make it they don't have
the baggage you do they'll go
okay and as they get older they'll ask
questions about
that is another we have another brother
we have another son
and as they get older that's when you
can begin to have more and more open
conversation
right now the word indiscretion i don't
even like that word
but the word i know but i it just feels
so i it doesn't know it is but it is
the um a seven-year-old wouldn't
understand what indiscretion meant
right right he would understand
um daddy has um had another little boy
that's older than you
with another mommy and that mommy lives
in so-and-so
and hopefully one day we'll get to
everybody will get to play but he's
older than you right now
and your kid will go huh what's his name
and you'll say tom and you'll go oh
can i have some nachos that's how
they'll absorb this story okay
and what what you don't want to do is
communicate
anything other than i'm just telling you
the truth and
as they age this conversation gets
deeper
and more whole and bigger i had a
conversation with my son
last night he's 10 now and we were
talking about integrity and honesty and
i had to tell him
your dad lied a lot when he was a kid i
was real insecure
and i just didn't tell the truth a lot
which is why i'm a lunatic about it now
and he couldn't have heard that at seven
at seven it was
daddy got in trouble a lot when he was a
kid you know what i mean right
and so again you just slowly open it up
like a funnel
but i think you are dead on and i love
your heart here you can't have secrets
just destroy families
um if you have a picture if this
eventually there's a pen pal thing maybe
your husband puts a self
a dress stamped envelope in there and
gives this young kid an opportunity to
write him back
um even puts paper in there and says i'd
love to hear from you i've put an
envelope in there you may lose that
envelope for five years
but it's year six that you get that
letter back right and that letter may
come back with just a traced middle
finger on it right
and your husband just has to know i'm
not getting my feelings hurt by a 14
year old i'm just not
and i'm going to write some we we've
sent some
um and in the beginning we used to send
cards and we would send gifts and we
sent all of these things and and it was
pretty much all rejected
um and so we recently found him on
a social media site yep and so he
reached out to him directly through that
um and so he just that's kind of been
you know he hasn't responded but again
trying to at least say i'm here when
you're ready to talk i'm
you know and again not talking at all
about his mother because we don't want
it to be
that's right your mother is so horrible
and we are so great
um everybody has to answer for their
choices in this situation
and he'll figure if you really want to
figure out he will figure out deception
from mom he will figure out mom is not
who she said she was she'll figure out
why did we move 14 different places when
i was like
he'll figure that out and it may be that
mom is rejecting these letters
you don't know right it may be that mom
is hitting return on these things
and you have no idea the poison that
she's filling that poor little boy with
and it may be that one day you have a
box of letters that you
hand to him i hope you keep every one of
those things that gets returned hope you
keep
everything because at one point that
will be part of the conversation
and you just want um not only do you
want to trail
i don't want my husband giving up on his
son
right i don't be married to that guy so
i want him to continue it sounds like
he's not right i'm not putting that out
there but no
he's going for it and going for it go
for it reach out on social media that's
always a
paltry chick and crap second option
right and not it's just not a way to
communicate with
with people that you love always be
sending cards always be sending letters
i love just handwritten letters man
and um keep sending them keep sending
them keep sending them and she may burn
every one of them
great it's not going to hurt him but
yeah your original question yes you got
to tell the little kids and i would
tell them in a way that um preserves
everybody's dignity right now
doesn't let them be surprised and maybe
you introduce it with a photo
and kind of like my daughter she's five
we like
she curls up and looks at old photo
albums and look this is when you were in
mommy's tummy
it may be you know who that is that
little boy is your brother
that's your brother daddy has another
son who's way older than you with
another mommy
and they'll go how does that work then
you may have to explain some stuff
but you can start it so they'll have a
picture in their head and then they're
just going to go on about their day
and never never lie to your kids
tell them the truth i love your heart
melissa this is a hard one this is a
tough one
um but lean into the hard conversation
it's gonna be hard
and lean don't give up chasing that
little boy all right let's go
to sean in raleigh north carolina sean
what's up how are we doing
hey there john thanks for having me on
the show i appreciate your time hey
brother thanks for calling how can i
help ma'am
all right so i've got a really difficult
family situation and
normally i'm chock full of solutions but
this just has me
at my wit's end and this is the first
time i've ever done something like this
so
i need some help on this uh so i'm going
to give you the short
abbreviated version and then i guess we
kind of fill in details as we uh as we
need to
so a couple of years ago i found out
uh that my dad is being abused by my mom
okay and it's been going on here i don't
know
physically or psychologically
emotionally psychologically emotionally
nothing nothing physical
they've been married for going on 40
years now
okay and it's been based in a lot of
fear
and paranoia on her end
i grew up with it too i'm an only child
so it was just
me and my dad there and as i was growing
up
i didn't know anything different i
didn't
realize what was going on that it wasn't
normal
uh but there was just a lot of
controlling on her
end in every little thing imaginable
sure and growing up you know
that kind of i kind of i guess caught
that so to speak and i didn't have any
friends growing up as a result because i
was always trying to control everybody
else
and you know thankfully i've been
because of my wife she's helped me
you know grow out of that and i see the
issue but
a few years ago you know my dad when
they came to visit
us here we live several states away they
came to visit
and he just unleashed all these problems
that have been going on
i mean it was just like he could not
hold it back anymore
this is just 30-something years where
he's been treated like a three-year-old
in every little way when you say
unleashed did he just you all just went
out
and had a cigar and he just told you a
bunch of stuff or he
snapped and was yelling in the middle of
the house
no it was it was when my my wife and my
mom they went out somewhere and
he and i were just alone together and
then he just it just kind of like a damn
broke and then all he was just
telling me about all these problems
they've been having he's a
he's a very relaxed guy he's you know
very non-confrontational he's high in
agreeableness uh but he just
you know was saying that they've been
having these massive blow up
fights for several years now i'm 27 i've
been out of the house for you know about
five or six years
but and they never did this growing up
but
you know where they're yelling and
screaming at each other he's going out
in the yard and throwing stuff around
kicking stuff up so this has been going
on for quite some time but then
over the summer with the whole pandemic
social upheaval it just got to be 100x
and as i said before she's very afraid
and very
paranoid about things i mean i remember
one time where
she made me get rid of a video game
because she believed that the design on
the cover jacket would
bring demonic forces into the house yes
how was that type of thing oh man wow
and just and just things like that that
you know and me have been building up
resentment
so so fast forward to now how can i help
you
all right so it got 100x like i said and
it got to the point where
again my dad just reached out to me by
text this massive text just profanity
extreme
just telling me about how he can't take
it anymore because he's
been at the point where he said that he
just wants to die
mm-hmm he told me a couple months after
the fact that he had a suicide plan
yikes and he almost went through with it
if not for divine intervention i really
believe that he
would have and thankfully now you know
he says that he's not
in that position anymore but he's still
just saying that
you know he'd rather just dive and live
and the
part of the problem right now is that i
know all about this stuff i know about
his psychological state
i know about just how difficult it is
with him but my mom does not know that i
know
and for years i've been living basically
this double existence and
psychologically i just do not know how
to deal with it so
yeah so i think he's at the point where
they need to separate and i just want to
know how to handle this
yeah so i appreciate your heart for your
folks um you're carrying a lot
and after this call i'm gonna ask you to
put almost all the stuff down
okay so a couple of things
that you put out here and we're gonna go
through them systematically
okay um if your dad says i have a plan
then what you're gonna respond with is
you're gonna call
people in his life that love him or
you're gonna call 9-1-1 and you can tell
your dad i love you enough that i'm not
gonna let you kill yourself
i'm not period and unfortunately you're
in a position that
many many many grown kids how old are
you
27 27 how long you been married
uh going on four years now okay so
you're in a in a position happens all
the time millions
millions of people in the same position
where you suddenly
start having to parent your parents okay
you become the adult in this
relationship and some of it is
your dad is watching you in this new
relationship
he may see something in between you and
your wife that reminds him of his young
marriage or he may see something that
just makes it is so beautiful he
realizes he never had that
partridge in a pear tree here's the deal
i don't care what he's seeing
for some reason he feels safe enough to
tell you hey i'm out
i love you i'm out and you have is not
by your hand but in your lap it got
dropped in your lap and you're gonna
deal with it
i will not let my dad kill himself at
least to the best of my ability i'm
gonna call in every calvary i have and
that i know
the second thing is give your dad
permission
to separate from your mom okay and i
don't know if he's asking for that it
sounds like he might be
give him permission dad if you need to
get away get away come stay with us
feel free to come stay with us here's
the thing about your mom
she will never hear it okay i know any
sort of explanation you give to her
she'll never hear
any sort of anything she's not going to
hear it and so what i'm going to suggest
is
not you feel like you're curing this
psychological burden that you have and
you're living a double life
you're not just stop carrying it okay
you would not
talk just walk up to your mom and start
talking spanish because you know what
you're talking about
this is the same thing so just put that
burden down
right you have a man who loves you a man
who feels vulnerable for whatever
reason you must be a great young man and
you must be doing great things with your
marriage he wouldn't trust you like this
and he's either testing you out like he
has to tell somebody he's crying out for
help
or um he's asking for permission and you
do not have my permission to hurt
yourself
you do have my permission you can move
into my basement for a season you can
move next door for a season you can
i will still love you if you have to
separate yourself um
in a not safe situation but you're not
gonna kill yourself
and what you need to do at this moment
is to
picture yourself you feel 27 and you
feel like your dad is
you need to picture yourself at 45 i'm
standing up tall and i'm going to start
making some of these very clear
decisions
the next thing you need to tell your dad
is you are not allowed to
dump this stuff on me you've got to find
professionals and friends your own age
that are able to handle this stuff
and he may curl up in a ball but he is
you are not his um receptacle his trash
can for
marital issues you're a son does that
make sense
yeah he was working with a psychologist
for a while
and you know he talked he told my mom to
come there but it's
she doesn't see any of this as an issue
so you're i mean you're right i mean
it's you know just all fear paranoia
just for so many years these tracks have
just been worn down in her mind
if i brought any of this stuff up you
know it's not going to make any
difference so you're you're right about
that um so all right all your dad can do
is take care of himself
right and if he's making suicide plans
um
one of the common misconceptions is that
suicide is the problem
it's not for people who are in his
situation
suicide is a solution and if he feels
like a burden to other people
and he feels like he's gonna hurt and
that hurt is never ever gonna stop
and he's got no one to go to suicide is
a solution
to that hurt right and what you have to
do is ring every bell there is you will
not do that
and i would have a hard hard
conversation with him directly
like i am your son and i love you more
than anything in the world except for my
wife
and you are not going to kill yourself
and i'll say oh i
know i'm saying no no no dad you are not
going to kill yourself period and if i
hear about you making a suicide plan i
will call in the calvary i'll call in
9-1-1 i'll call in every psychologist i
know of in your area
i will ring every bell there is because
i love you too much to let you do that
i would love you to take a break for mom
and come stay with me
i would love you to take a break from
mom come rent an apartment in this
junky apartment complex down the street
from my house you and i will go fishing
and hang out
but i want you to get away from there
and you've got to go see somebody
yeah i've been i talked to him about
two or three weeks ago and that was the
first time i suggested he may have to
leave and it was i thought you know
thinking about that
you know when he told me that he was
taking you know
i forget what the name of the
prescription was but he was taking
double the maximum dosage and three
benadryls and a drink on top of that
just to numb the pain that's when i came
to the solution that i think this needs
to end
well yeah he's just on a dangerous
slippery slope brother
and yeah whatever whatever psychiatrist
is writing
him that type of prescription and
letting him take it in that way
should have their medical license
removed um
but it is what it is well he's doing
more than the maximum dose what he
which he was prescribed so he's yeah but
at some point you run
out halfway before your prescription
should have run out and then they'll
just give you another one
right that's what i'm talking about yeah
he can double up no one can stop him
from doing that but they can stop him
from getting another one
until it's time right and they often
don't
but that's a whole other conversation um
but yeah i think being real direct with
him and letting him know how much you
love him
and letting him know that he's got a
place to land with you
um again when folks can
i've got nowhere to go and not only do i
not have anyone to go
to but if i do i'm a burden to them
because i guarantee you sean
when he after he left your house he beat
himself up for putting that crap
on you he did he beat himself up he
finally had
he finally just let it out to the one
guy he trusts
which is the son and then he beat
himself up about it and that's that
burdensome loop right just piling it on
piling it on he needs to know you're
safe
you got boundaries and you may how about
this
um get with your wife and identify these
boundaries can dad come stay with us for
a month
can dad move into an apartment down the
street
um can i afford to get on a plane ticket
and go
meet with a counselor with my dad can i
do that once do we can we have the money
to do that
and can i look my dad in the eye over
coffee and say i'm
blessing you in your journey to be well
you're not doing okay
and then you're gonna deal with mom but
you're not gonna mom's not gonna hear
any of this stuff
right um she needs some professional
help as well
this is a tough one man you're gonna
have to lean in
and make real hard grown-up decisions
and have real hard grown-up boundaries
and this is the hardest part you cannot
connect yourself to the outcome
what do i mean by that if your dad does
the unthinkable and hurts himself
takes his life that will not be sean's
fault
i'll even go as far as say that will not
be your mom's fault
there will be a cocktail of reasons why
that happened both
way before you even born and and and
and and if your dad moves in with you
and stays with you for a couple of
months and your marriage gets goofy you
and your wife
have to work really hard
you can't hold yourself to the outcome
of this what you can't hold yourself to
is what you can control which is your
attitude
your approach your direction your
boundaries
and your love for both of your parents
that's it man this heart relationships
are hard parenting is hard
and man we will be thinking about your
dad i want to know how that conversation
goes with your old man
so when after you have that conversation
pause for a minute and then shoot me an
email let me know what you told them let
me know how it goes
and um if he wants to call the show i'd
love to talk to him and if you want to
give me a call back i'd love to talk to
you again sean thank you so much
um we have one more quick email here
before we wrap up the show
um this is part of a series of emails we
get all these all the time
and so we came up with a
came up with something to help folks in
this situation um
it sounds connected to that last call
with sean but it's not
the emails from will says if something
happens to me
i want to make sure my kids go to the
right folks the right people
there are family members i would want to
take them and other members that i
definitely
wouldn't want to take them should i have
these conversations
now the answer is unequivocally
the moment you have a kid
the moment you find out you're pregnant
you must
have the conversation about who will
take these kids if we die
and after you decide who will take these
kids you will then have that
conversation
with the person that you hope will take
your kids
because you can be in a car wreck on the
way home from the hospital for god's
sake
and you do not want the state government
of whatever state you live in deciding
to
clear that mess out not my family man it
would all be
smooth and easy i'm telling you i've
been there
i've sat with people and it is not clean
it is a mess
people come out of the woodwork and
start suing each other and folks who are
the most
quiet placid kind people go to war with
each other
over money and over family members or
they abandoned them ah i don't have time
for that i don't have the money for that
i don't have the room for that
um maybe uncle whoever over in another
state can
do the right thing have the hard
conversation but here's the thing i know
that conversation's hard
the last thing you want to talk about
when you have a little kid is
well we might die and someone else is
going to have to take the kid you don't
want to have that conversation that
comes
hard it's awkward and i say this over
and over
just talking to sean life is full of
hard conversations and harsh realities
it just
is and the earlier you can have those
the earlier you can set those
foundations up
you just sleep with peace right
so our team put together the how to talk
about your legacy guide that will help
you have right conversations before
and after some of these big life
transitions a lot of this is focused on
making a will
part of making a will is deciding if we
both die who takes our kids
where are they going to go live um and
this
guide will help you plan to how to plan
your conversations how to get on the
same page with your spouse
how to ask people to be the executor how
to ask people to be the kids
guardian or power of attorney that's an
awkward conversation i've had to do it
several times it's weird i've had
somebody tell me no
that's life and i didn't hate him for it
we just had to move on so
i want you to text legacy to 33789 and
get your free how to talk about your
legacy guide today
that's legacy 33789
um the folks here put this together and
hopefully it will help you
and your family have some of these hard
hard conversations just do it just do it
just do it all right so as we wrap up
today's show
man one of my favorite albums in the
history of albums
one of the greatest poets man some of
his records are
you just listen to him you're like i
don't actually know what's happening
right now i think my brain's imploding
on the inside out
he's that kind of artist he's brilliant
he's
brilliant where he levels up right
but he came out with one of my favorite
records ever in 1999
the name of the record was called mule
variations
by the one and only legendary tom waits
on that album there's just incredible
song after incredible song after
incredible song
one of my favorites is called since i
put your picture in a frame
and it doesn't have many words but it's
a poem and if you listen to him sing it
it gets way way way into your soul
so on mule variations 1999 tom waits
since i put your picture in a frame he
writes the sun
come up it was blue and gold the sun
come up and it was blue and gold
ever since i put your picture in a frame
i come calling in my sunday best
i come calling in my sunday best ever
since i put your picture
in a frame and i'm gonna love you till
the wheels come off
and i love you baby and i always will
love you baby
and i always will ever since i put your
picture
in a frame stop what you're doing right
now and go listen to tom waits
ever since i put your picture in a frame
this has been the dr john dolone show
you